this was really an extraordinary thing
this week so everyone watching my show
gets the the fight against critical race
theory and of course the big story was
that merrick garland our attorney
general in essence was sicking the
department of justice on parents who
were showing up to school board meetings
to fight against it not because they
were actually doing anything truly
threatening but he was in essence
calling parents who show up and say hey
i want to be involved in my kids
education he was calling them domestic
terrorists well he had to testify this
week and it got a little spicy let's
take a look
you've cited
as the basis for that directive
the national school board association's
letter of september 29th was that
directive
being prepared before september 29th
before the school board association
letter was issued i don't believe so
certainly i didn't have any idea so it
was only prepared okay i think that
answers the question already answered so
you keep citing the school board letter
and news reports news right one of the
news reports signed in that letter which
you presumably mean
is from loudoun county virginia no
that's not that is not um what i was
talking about well you keep citing news
reports and that's the most prominent
news report that anyone in america has
seen that refers to scott smith whose 15
year old daughter was raped
she was raped
in a bathroom by a boy wearing girls
clothes and the loudoun county school
board covered it up because it would
have interfered with their transgender
policy during pride month
and that man scott smith because he went
to a school board and tried to defend
his daughter's rights was condemned
internationally do you apologize to
scott smith and his 15-year-old daughter
judge
senator anyone whose uh child was raped
as uh as a most horrific crime i can
imagine and is certainly entitled and
protected by the first amendment to
protest to their school board about that
but he was cited by the school board
association that's fine he's a domestic
terrorist which we now know that letter
and those reports were the basis for
your job
this is that's wrong judges is shameful
this here this testimony your directive
your performance is shameful that's not
thank god you are not on the supreme
court
you should resign in disgrace judge
that that moment by tom cotton right
there at the end it's like we have so
many politicians who refuse to say
anything true and he just really dropped
something true there so just
sean go ahead go ahead it felt like it
was reminiscent of the malt when mueller
was testifying how like ill-prepared he
was i mean i i don't know if garland's
staff
prepared him
like looked at a newspaper or did a
google search about key issues because
he looked flat-footed throughout the
entire process and i felt like
that as a someone who has staffed a lot
of principles in the past that it was a
real dis either he doesn't know what's
going on or his staff let him down or
both but
the idea that he he seemed so
ill-prepared for this hearing and
understanding the source materials that
he had to have known were coming his way
really was to me the big takeaway yeah
so liz is this story
just like the perfect example of almost
everything in essence he got a one-page
letter that has since pretty much been
retracted saying that parents are
domestic terrorists he references that
letter and then he says media reports
are saying that parents are domestic
terrorists so we're going to do
something here at the the department of
justice and of course when i saw the
story breaking and i saw cnn picking it
up in msnbc picking up whatever else i
was like something doesn't add up here
like they've got one piece of paper next
thing you know the media is reporting on
it the fact that he even uses the media
as if that is evidence of anything
doesn't it just tell you how just what a
perfect storm of nonsense this is
and by by the way too the woman who
crafted that letter from the school
board association the national school
board association and senate to uh
merrick garland she now has a position
in the biden administration on um on the
education governing board in the biden
administration this is after she wrote
that letter so the biden administration
is not even pretending that this is an
aberration or a mistake or an isolated
incident no no they're embracing this
this is why dave this is why yunkin is
up by eight points according to the
latest fox news poll in virginia because
it's no longer the left versus the right
this is the left versus parents
everywhere you don't have to be a
republican a republican or a
conservative or anything close to
understand that your daughter is at risk
if men are allowed in in the bathroom
with her that your child is at risk if
they're going to be indoctrinated with
ideology that teaches them that they're
racist if they have white skin and
oppressed if they have black skin this
is no longer a partisan fight this is
parents versus the left and the left
instead of doing what they normally do
and pretending that they don't embrace
this radical view they are actually
doubling down and it's causing parents
to be like well then you don't represent
me and we're going to vote for your
opponent as they should right so this is
sort of eric's point from earlier sean
do you think we kind of owe them a
thanks in a way when they've gone so far
where they will tell you that we're
going to inject your kids with stuff and
by the way we don't know what's going to
happen until we do it then we'll figure
it out or we say we're going to call you
all domestic terrorists for not wanting
this neo-racism in school it's like it's
one thing to attack the adults but now
that they've shifted it to the kids
maybe we do owe them a thanks here
because the great awakening might be
upon us
yeah i agree i think that's absolutely
right you think about how many people
are now engaged in the political process
that weren't otherwise they're attending
school board hearings that are running
for the school board but then the the
worst part is that you have barack obama
coming into virginia talking about it
being a made-up controversy a right-wing
thing i mean the bottom line is i
literally have a chapter in my book
radical nation documenting its origins
what it seeks to achieve this is not
made up this is very real and in school
district after school district parents
are having these conversations i talked
to one parent about a month and a half
ago was telling me that they have to
write essays as parents talking about
how in the home they are addressing
their white privilege with their kids
and it's like that the parents and if
they don't do it and then i talk about
one other example where there's a woman
who's actually asian she came out
against some of the things that were
going on in the school and the group of
parents that were supporting this called
her employer called the hr department
and said we just wanted to alert you to
some of her racist behavior outside of
the workplace in case anything comes up
inside the workplace you know that it's
a pattern but these are the tactics that
they are employing to get their way and
to cancel and shout down everybody
man our work is cut out for us but i
would love if i if a teacher ever asked
me to write a letter like that i would
be absolutely happy to send one back to
the school tongue and exactly what i
think of white privilege